[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
guess who's back guess who's back guess
who's back that's right [__]
the suspension is over I'm out of
YouTube jail
on the main account
everyone's been wondering where the hell
I'm at we've been over on the up wire
Channel That's where we've been
I it's not a ban evasion it's not a band
evasion I was streaming over there prior
to us getting banned here on the main
Channel
and we're still we're still streaming
over on the up bar Channel by the way
that's where we have been hiding
it's not a band evasion that's my stance
so go to the upwire.com the upr.com or
just search the up wire on YouTube and
subscribe to that channel in case
we were to get suspended again
um I tried to get the word out to you I
promise
a lot of people followed a lot of people
um was looking and they found the up
wire
um
so
here we are here we are uh yesterday I
promised that I would get a promo code
out for the [__] em hats you can see I
have the red [__] hat on today the
blue one is right down here if you look
if you're looking on screens right here
there's a gray one up here
um and there's several different
versions on the hat store so what you do
here's what you do if you want the promo
code for the Hat just go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com scroll down just a bit
you'll see the hat store there's the
merch store there's the hat store and
then Gabe Sanchez's merch store but if
you want the hats go to the hat store
and the hat uh the promo code is the
same as the
always the promo code on the regular
store it's podcast that's podcast you
get 10 off your purchase at the hat
store on [__] em hats so just go to the
Tony michaels.com scroll down click the
hat store link use the promo code
podcast for ten percent off your [__] em
hats and you know what do me a favor do
me a favor
when you get it post a picture on on
social media with your [__] them head on
preferably out in public tell them to go
[__] themselves that's all I'm saying
that's all I'm saying we're back we're
[__] back it's Tuesday we're back on
the main Channel
it feels good and there's you know news
today uh not a ton of news but there is
news there is news today the big news is
that Grandpa and meatball
are having a sausage fight and it's not
going so well for them
they're trying to they're trying to out
Hitler each other and Ben Shapiro is
really he does not like that people are
comparing Donald Trump and desantos to
Hitler he does not like that he does not
like that for whatever reason I guess
you know when Nazis show up in Ohio
to back the daily wires entire
personality
of trying to eradicate a group of people
in this country because of who they are
I guess it really does when Ben Shapiro
he's a Jewish he's a Jewish man it
really feels he's in a he's in a tough
spot he really isn't a tough spot when
neo-nazis and Nazis show up in Ohio to
support daily wire
it's really it's kind of [__] weird
it's kind of but it isn't [__] weird
if you go back and you study
um there was a country
man it was in the 1920s 30s and 40s but
really they came to um rise in fascism
in the 30s and 40s
it's in Europe I believe
starts with a GED Germany maybe
um
a lot of people don't know this
but in the early days of the uh Nazi
takeover it was Elite Jews it was Elite
Jewish people who helped the Nazis come
to power a lot of people don't know that
and the way that they they did that is
they were complicit in in their rhetoric
against the common Jewish people
a lot of people don't know that and you
know who you know who you know who was
the first you know who was the first
to be dead
in Germany as far as the Holocaust is
concerned those Elite Jewish people who
were complicit so it doesn't it seems
weird that Ben Shapiro is all Hitler
this Hitler that when neo-nazis are in
Ohio protesting Republican Nazis are in
Ohio real Republican Nazis holding Nazi
Flags
are pushing the agenda of the daily wire
it's really you know it feels weird but
it is not this is how fascism takes hold
in a [__] country
now we're under a lot different
circumstances than Nazi Germany or
Germany for that matter was in the 1920s
and the 1930s we're in a lot different
situation and I know I know people would
disagree with me on that but if you go
back and look at the shape that the
country Germany was in and the the the
the the political uh
um newbies that were coming to power in
that country and the the the fight for
power in that country uh was much
different than it is today
much different they were battered by the
first world war
um a lot of them were disgruntled
by the non-nationalism of their Nation
after they were crushed in the first
world war so and which Hitler was in the
Nazi party was in the lead of that so it
is different meaning the landscape is
different but the methods are the same
that they're using and and it's because
it's fascism that that's why it seems
very similar because it is
it is very similar not only similar it's
a lot alike
um so when Ben Shapiro the the the head
of the daily wire who is
um leading the March against groups of
people in this country against our
countrymen for who they want to be the
eradication
of people in our country I don't give a
[__] what you say bench Ben Shapiro come
sue me send a cease and desist you
little [__]
you are leading the march of Nazis to
eradicate people in this country is what
you're doing with your little daily wire
you Matt Walsh and Michael Knowles you
[__] and Candace Owens you [__]
pieces of garbage
and if you don't like it if you don't
like it that's not my problem that
neo-nazis and Republicans carrying Nazi
flags are protesting in on your behalf
in Ohio
drag shows you you [__] slugs so
um it's a it's a weird day it's a weird
day it's a weird day
that Ben Shapiro is really upset that
people are comparing Donald Trump
and desantos to Hitler
um but fascists are going to fascist
that's just what they're going to do
that is how they're going to do it now
we're going to combat it here on the
Tony Michaels butt guess we're not going
to shut up we're not going to be
silenced no matter what YouTube does
again
I want to thank you for following us and
playing hide and seek all around the
internet
uh with the show you guys showed up uh
in big numbers on the other platforms
and on the up wire Channel again go to
the upwire.com or go to the up wire
Channel on YouTube and uh subscribe
there also we're going to start tweeting
from the Twitter account so again if you
go to the upwire.com the links are there
you can go follow the Twitter account uh
um the up wire is going to start
tweeting from there
um some of it might be me some of it
might be some other folks uh at the up
wire but just um just be aware that
there is a Twitter account that will
start tweeting from also you guys showed
up in DeRose on Twitch
um and and that's exciting I don't know
let me see how many subscriptions are
over there now
wow you guys almost 80 subscriptions
over there a lot of new follows
um I don't know if you know this but
Amazon Prime allows you to have one free
subscription on Twitch so you can here's
what you can do if you link your Amazon
Prime account with the Twitch account
you can actually give us your one free
subscription and we get a few dollars of
Just Jeff bezos's money well it's
Amazon's money but you know what the
[__] I mean
so and if you do that you just link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account and subscribe with your one free
subscription that you get with your
Amazon Prime account and it helps out
the show also you guys showed up big on
Facebook hundreds of people are showing
up to watch on Facebook I know you guys
are on the Midas touch Channel and on my
channel but you if you're not following
my channel on Facebook yet go to FD Tony
Michaels and then also follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod and
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast money through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
after we're done here recording I posted
on all the directories
so I'm not telling you to go to all the
directories and download it
I might be telling you that I'm just
kidding I might be saying yes go to go
to every single directory and download
that son of a [__]
it helps us in the rankings we've been
moving up in the rankings
um uh over the last several days let's
see on the podcast directories ah we
fell we fell a little bit these [__]
rankings are weird in Ireland we're
number 70 we moved up 53 spots over the
last day the the podcast directory
rankings are weird I'm not really sure
exactly I haven't figured those out yet
the algorithm over there is a [__]
um because there's apple and then there
because Apple has their algorithm Google
has their algorithm you know all these
all these directories have their own
algorithms built into how it it you know
feeds you up the podcast but just go to
the Tony michaels.com the Tony
michaels.com
all the links are there they're all at
the Tony michaels.com don't forget that
the Tony michaels.com and also you can
check out our patreon page there at the
tonymichaels.com
oh boy we've got uh several still over
on the up wire holy moly we're we're
getting in our audience here we're
getting our audience back today today's
Tuesday we have Texas Paul with us today
um we do not have Gabe Sanchez and he's
still on vacation I think I believe he's
gonna be back on Thursday so don't tune
out just because the the um the Mexican
hunk of love is not here uh he will be
back I promise he will be back now today
we have Texas Paul with us though so we
should we should have a big audience
Texas Paul usually uh draws an audience
like [__] draws flies
um I'm sure he'll like that analogy
and he's there laughing he says he's
giving me middle fingers as we speak
um so Texas fall is going to uh help us
um uh slam dunk these fascists and get
through this news uh did you hear did
you hear the Republicans really tried
hard to collapse our economy over the
last several days oh my God they were
trying so hard to get people to go make
runs on the bank and social media oh man
it was a [__] they had they so
much so that they they tried so hard on
social media to get a frenzy to go uh
make run on runs on Banks and and and
really honestly these uh these Russian
uh Nazis and these Republican Nazis
Nazis are one and the same they're
really trying to get their bot Farms to
um get people to make run on banks they
actually closed uh two Banks I believe
is the two that they closed the one was
the one everyone was talking about which
was Silicon Valley Bank
um and Janet Yellen and um the FDIC told
uh the Silicon Valley bank managers and
the uh investors the shareholders there
to go [__] themselves that the
depositors are the ones that we are
concerned about the same thing for a
couple other banks that started to feel
faulty but because our Administration
and because we elected a president who
is confident enough to put competent
people in charge of these things they
did a magnificent job of making sure
that the American people were secure
even with these Republicans out there
trying on trying their damnedest trying
their damnedest on social media to get
the economy to collapse because they
really they don't give a [__] about you
they don't give a [__] about you they
don't give a [__] about it the economy
collapses on you or not they don't give
a [__] it's good for their [__] it's
good for their narrative
I mean if you want to compare it to
things we politicize like I politicize
mass shootings that's right I said it I
politicize mass shootings I don't give a
[__] what you think and I don't care if
you don't like it you [__] kick rocks
or just be pissed and comment please
just be pissed and comment I mean you
can kick rocks too
but they're they were politicizing and
encouraging a collapse of the economy
collapse of the banking system is what
they were what they were wanting because
then it would be done on Biden's watch
well it really is [__] Rich that they
tried their damnedest to make sure that
the FDIC failed and that the American
people lost confidence in their Banks
and they didn't what does that tell you
even on the face of these people trying
to go to war with you the [__]
working class they're going to war with
you
their Civil War is against you Jesus
Christ we had people who were yelling
and screaming that it's unconstitutional
and socialism and blah blah blah on and
on and on when Joe Biden
signed the student debt relief act or a
student debt relief executive order
excuse me
and he was going to relieve Americans
working Americans of their [__]
student debt
oh that's unconstitutional that's
socialism as if as if the government
loaning [__] money for student loans
is it socialism in the first place you
stupid [__] what do you think the FDIC
is what do you think federally backed
student loans are you you [__] trash
ass [__]
these are the same bastards that were
begging begging the government to give
bailouts not to the depositors because
they don't give a [__] about the
depositors folks they wanted the
investors and the management to get
bailed out at svb [__] them [__] them
here's what I think also anyone who is
on management or who is an investor in
svb should have their rights stripped of
them to invest or manage a bank ever
again
[__] you
you suck at this you're horrible at this
you made really bad [__] decisions
I don't give a [__] what the regulations
were and how Trump pushed them back and
allowed you to do whatever the [__] you
wanted you made really stupid ass
decisions
and you put a lot of [__] people's
money at risk that you're supposed to be
the Safeguard of in a [__] bank
particularly Peter teal and the [__]
Founders fund that [__]
Peter Thiel should never be able to
allow him to be invest in a bank
anywhere ever again after this I hope
the [__] committed federal
crimes and we find it and they [__]
prosecute that son of a [__]
it's enough of this [__]
it's enough of us [__] have to run
around worrying about the rich losing
losing a little bit of their [__]
money and our livelihood and our economy
being tanked because Republicans are
trying to encourage an economic and Bank
collapse because it's good for Trump you
dumb [__]
guess what didn't happen though guess
what didn't happen if you're standing
around still wondering why the country
hates your [__] guts Republicans and
moglodytes it's because of this they
[__] hate your guts
and they don't want anything to do with
your [__] ideology
where all you do is cow Tao to [__]
billionaires and suck them off
and it is only clear that Donald Trump
has lost his mind and Rhonda santis
can't find his
they're [__] and Donald Trump is gonna
be their nominee and I again a couple
weeks ago I told you I think we're
moving into the 14 15 million uh vote
margin between Joe Biden and Donald
Trump I believe we're moving into the 16
to 17 million uh deficit margin between
the two I think Joe Biden will win
in 2024 by 16 or 17 million at this
point if they we were voting today
that guy has lost his [__] mind Ron
DeSantis
um Gabe Sanchez tweeted this he said
that uh
the Republicans uh jumped the woke shark
what a bunch of dumb [__]
but this is this is this is what they
want to do this is the [__] they
want to spread so let's encourage them
to do it
let's encourage them
we have competent people at the wheel
folks
I don't know if you have any idea how
bad the this Bank Run could have been
but it could have been terrible if the
country believed Maga
and didn't believe that the government
our government us the people that we
elected to be competent in the
government
we're going to make sure that the
depositor's money was safe
because that's the one thing that these
[__] Rich ass [__] don't
understand you ain't rich without us
[__]
you are not rich without us and that GDP
that GDP you don't get all of it we get
some of it [__]
and it's only clear it's only clear now
um I read somewhere I don't remember who
the [__] it was they said something
about
Mike Pence is now found an opening in
the Republican primary you you people
you're just I mean it is so funny to
watch these Republicans who have [__]
capitulated to this fascism to all of a
sudden be just clamoring for someone
like Nikki Haley or Mike Pence or Larry
Hogan or sununu get the [__] out of here
they ain't got a [__] chance
and when Donald Trump is indicted I'm
telling you bank on it doubt me you
[__] do it I Dare You When
Donald Trump is indicted and it looks
like uh we're getting very close uh in
the Manhattan DA's office I guess
Michael Cohen is there again today he
was there yesterday for three [__]
hours they want to talk to him more now
which doesn't indicate that the grand
jury isn't taking Michael Cohen's
testimony in front of them unseriously
they're taking it very seriously think
about it three [__] hours then they
want him to come back today and talk for
another three [__] hours kellyanne
Conway was there three times I think
hope Hicks did like five or six hours in
front of him it's coming [__] and
Donald Trump's attorneys have said no
he's not going to go because he he will
self-incriminate himself
those charges are coming now I don't
know if um Manhattan will strike first
or Georgia or uh Jack Smith we know we
know those those three prosecutors are
the one Donald Trump fears the most
because that's the one he's posting
about the most
I mean it's [__] insane have you guys
seen this motherfucker's post on on
fraud social oh my God maybe we should
go show a few of those today because he
is absolutely losing his mind Andy's
posting these videos and Liz Liz
Harrington I know you're listening Liz
uh Liz tunes into the show Liz
Harrington she's one of his social media
people
uh the only reason why I say Liz tunes
into the show is because me and Gabe
Sanchez early on in these Trump videos
that he does in front of the fireplace
with the flags and it's all dark and
[__] and he's painted up orange
um
and the lighting's horrible the cuts are
horrible we were doing these um we were
bringing the videos on the show and we
were
um you know critiquing them not based on
what he said well that too but more like
how it was shot what the cuts the cuts
were horrible the lighting was horrible
why are they watching this and you know
why are they colorizing this cut not
that cut and I I think Liz was listening
because I think she's helping with that
team to produce that garbage over there
for Trump and his campaign but these
videos that they've been producing Liz
God damn you got to get this guy out you
got to stop recording him holy [__] it
is getting bad now I mean it's good it's
good for the primary oh this is all good
for the primary this is going to secure
him the nomination I mean that's the
idea because he wants to he wants to
fend off a trial in 2024. but man this
is horrible I mean it's getting bad
again we're getting into the 16 million
uh vote margin I think where Joe Biden
is going to win by double what he won
last time I'm not [__] you I'm not
[__] [__] you by the time you get
people who claim to be Republicans who
won't vote for these slugs
because they're sick and tired of their
mess
and their [__]
and then you get people and not only is
Gen Z coming of age
but you get more people engaged in your
democracy like we have here on the show
and you get louder and louder and louder
against these fascists
I'm telling you I'm telling you it's
it's going to have an impact over a long
period of time and it feels like a short
period between now and 2024 but that's a
long ways to go
and we gotta keep yelling and screaming
and pointing out this [__] and we have
to encourage we have to encourage that
the Republican Party
pick one of the Nazis
we really do they need to pay for this
folks politically and how we make them
pay for this politically is not give
them the opportunity to pick some
[__] moderate
as some would say and give them the
opportunity to win the presidency and
then [__] genuflect the Trump like
Kevin McCarthy did [__] that [__]
Kevin McCarthy oh he's he's not he's not
my girl he's not a well he genuflex to
Trump and Maga
so what else would you call it so we
cannot risk that we have to stay engaged
we have to [__] yell and scream we
have to be on top of these things and
that's why we need to put Trump versus
DeSantis
because that's the battle here that's
the real battle is Trump versus De
Santos and that's the fight we need to
encourage
that's that's the battle in the Civil
War that needs to happen in this country
in their own [__] party they're the
one that has to be fixed
just what we have to I mean again
I I don't know Republican Nazis they're
Nazis they were carrying Nazi Flags a
bunch of Republicans carrying Nazi Flags
showed up in Ohio over the weekend to
protest people dressed up in costumes
and they were dressed up in costumes I
showed you this yesterday we'll probably
show it again here not today with Texas
Paul just a bit of it but they showed up
in costumes
to protest people who were dressed up in
costumes but they were Republicans
carrying Nazi Flags
it's where we're at in this country I'm
sorry to say but we have to keep on it
suspension or no suspension that's right
I was suspended for seven days uh
there's more people on the show here now
so I'll go over this one more time I was
suspended for seven days on the main
account so if you're wondering where I'd
been at um we've been uh playing hide
and seek on the internet a lot of you
found us on the up wire Channel again if
you're on the up bars Channel right now
watching this uh subscriber go to the
upwire.com
And subscribe there it's a good place
just in case
just in case I'm not it's not been
evasion and the reason why is because we
were streaming this show over there the
funny part is here's the craziest part
about this
and I I haven't told you this until just
now so the episode that they Banned Me
on or suspended me on they put a seven
day suspension for harassment is what
they is that's what YouTube claimed that
I broke their guidelines with the rest
they never show me how or why they won't
tell you that I have no idea your guess
is as good as mine with that episode now
we were going to play the Jon Stewart
um clip where he's talking to the
Oklahoma representative about gun
control you remember this
it's a great clip it's it's [__] a
great video you should go out and watch
this and I guess it's spread it around
memorize the [__] memorize the
counterpoints that Jon Stewart makes
against this idiot this fascist
um his arguments against
gun control and just having anyone have
guns is more guns means uh safer which
is [__] but that video was I knew I
was going to show that video that day
so I didn't air that episode on the up
wire for that reason because I figured
it'd get flagged that's a new account I
didn't want it to get flagged there so
the funny part is is YouTube Banned Me
for airing that account on my and that
show on my main account
but I didn't air it over on up wire so
if they try to knock me for band evasion
I wasn't invading a ban I just I didn't
air that episode over on the up wire and
we've been uh streaming from the Umpire
for weeks
so but I don't think they knew that
you think I give a [__] [__] no I don't
give a [__] [__] them now speaking of
that people yesterday were asking about
a promo code for the hat store I'll say
that one more time uh before we go to a
break and bring in Texas Paul
um the [__] them hats if you go to the
Tony michaels.com the link you just
scroll down a bit the hat store link is
down there under merch there's the merch
store link the hat store link and then
Gabe Sanchez's merch uh store link go to
the hat store use the promo code podcast
that's the promo code podcast and you
get 10 off [__] em hats over on the [__]
em hat store so people were asking about
a promo code but it's podcast for 10 off
your purchase of a [__] hat
um
so uh um Texas Paul is having trouble
with his internet it looks like but um
we're gonna go to a break when we come
back it's Tuesday
it's Taco Tuesday so you know what that
means Texas Paul is here to join us so
everyone stick around we're gonna be
right back with Texas ball right after
this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
uh-oh
I guess the the uh promo code is limited
or something okay okay
we'll get a new one here I promise we'll
get a new one we'll get a new one I
promise I promise just hang tight hang
tight uh we're gonna welcome in Texas
ball Texas Paul how are you today
you gonna unmute there buddy every time
you're worse than Gabe Sanchez
[Music]
you're still not you're still muted
sorry about that there you go
he was gonna have a big jump in and he
he and the mute button got him all over
it
um so I'll tell you I'm I'm really
excited to be here I love Tuesdays
super excited to be here I am missing
Gabe though I'll be honest with you I am
missing Gabe none of them you know I
mean
nothing against you Tony I'm glad to be
here I love doing this with you but I'm
missing Gabe man
oh yeah
man I tell you what that's um that's a
shame I I miss Gabe too to be quite
honest
um and I know the audience uh Mrs Gabe
all customers I'm trying to get a uh a
promo code made here while we're talking
so like give me your opinion on I know
you did several videos on svb and this
banking situation
um so now that now that we're a few days
past this
um and we see that you know level heads
always Prevail
um tell me what you think about the the
lead up to svb crashing and then uh
Republicans really trying hard to get an
economic and Bank collapse and Janet
yelling having none of it protecting the
depositors oh my God Fox News just you
know I won't call them news anymore Fox
sitting there he wouldn't you know
literally calling for runs on banks
I mean how much more Traders can you get
and that is not anywhere near where
we're at folks anywhere near where we're
at these Banks
svb didn't have to die
it didn't it had great assets it had
great loans for companies that are doing
well
it just didn't have enough cash on hand
and these idiots these morons that are
invested in it caused a damn run on the
bank
I mean how how stupid can you get
literally cutting your nose off to spite
your face svb did not have to die and
then
God bless Jenny I swear to God she's a
Jedi man I swear to God that woman is a
Jedi she knew exactly what was going to
happen because they were not going to to
make the investors whole and I hope we
can talk about this later on Robert
Reich Robert Reich I don't know if
you've followed him
he was Clinton's economic advisor here I
mean he the guy's brilliant uh was
talking about this
do banks actually need do we need to
have do something about Banks having
shareholders
because you can't serve two masters
you know these Banks
Janet Yellen knew knew when they did
what they did to svb when they carved it
up put it up for auction and made the
depositors whole
and then told the investors sorry you
made a bad investment
um she knew there would be
investors trying to tank banks on Monday
trying to sell out of banks
driving their their stock value down
trying to get into bonds which is really
sweet right now because interest rates
are up
so she put a trade hold on 30 Banks
first thing Monday morning you are not
going to tank these Banks literally
you've got Janet Yellen lording over
these Banks fighting off these same
idiots that are bitching about Banks
failing
and they're trying to tank these Banks
because they want to get their money out
and screw everybody else right well I
think again and I said it in the first
30 minutes if you're if you were an uh a
man in management or a bigger a certain
size investor inside the svb you should
no longer be allowed or at least we
should give a time limit on when you can
be on management of another bank another
financial institution these people
should lose their ability to manage
these institutions if they can't manage
them correctly I mean
um we did this back in 2008 I was
[__] alive then I had a young family
then and these [__] Banks uh [__]
our entire economy uh the rich people in
this country walked away with loads of
money in their pocket with our taxpayer
Bill bailout and that may have been the
thing to do then but I think we learned
a lot from that and we we should protect
depositors so what the [__] FDIC is
there for that's what the insurance is
for that's what the American taxpayers
want is to protect the depositors and
[__] the investors if you if you [__] up
your bank that is not our problem that
is not that should not be our problem
and you should not be allowed to [__] up
any other Banks and I know people are
really pissed off at Peter Thiel as well
before we go I want I want to tell
everybody because in the chat people
worried about the promo code on the hats
I fixed the promo code podcast and you
can also use the promo cat
excuse me promo code hats10 that's hats
10 are the promo code podcast for 10 off
the hat store on your [__] em hat just
go to the Tony michaels.com scroll down
to the hat store you can use the promo
code podcast or the promo code hats10
they should both be working now I
apologize for for the indiscrepancy
there
um so Paul what do you think about this
the the Peter teal take on it because
him and his Founders fund they bailed on
this [__] right before it
started to go south and it's almost like
it's almost like that was the intentions
to get it to go south
um it feels like that what do you think
uh you know Peter Thiel actually this
isn't the first bank he tanked I mean I
sent you a link for glorify it died
right at the first of the year
the the anti-walk bank this is that's
what I'm laughing just hysterically
laughing politically James Comer said
that that it's a woke Bank yeah yeah
this is a bunch of [__] liberals and
not yeah
an anti-wolf Bank Peter Thiel put up a
bunch of money uh to help glorify get
started and it lasted three months three
months before it tanked you know I mean
it's it's just hilarious I mean I I
we want this guy in charge of financial
institutions what the [__] get the [__]
out of here
no and and we need to be real about this
people think Peter thiel's some sort of
Guru or some [__] like that no he just
he was just another guy that made a butt
load of money and and because a bunch of
people got together and had a good idea
you know I mean and and it's like Bill
Gates Bill Gates is no no guru he isn't
he came up with one idea
that was a good idea it was a different
way of doing something
um
it doesn't make him smart folks and
Peter Thiel is the same way
you know the Peter Thiel made his money
off of PayPal
you know it was a good idea it was a
good idea but it doesn't mean that he
knows everything about everything he
doesn't and just because he made a
buttload of money off PayPal
doesn't mean that all of a sudden he we
need to be taking advice from this guy
on any damn thing
I mean on anything at all I mean same
thing with Bill Gates it doesn't have to
be Peter Thiel I mean choose your
politics it doesn't matter Bill Gates
came up with an operating system for PCs
that I don't think everybody absolutely
loves so you know I don't follow Bill
Gates's advice on a whole lot of [__]
well you know I I think one of the
differences between some billionaires uh
is that some of them use their money for
good and some of them use it for bad and
I was saying that the other day in this
svb uh instance and even in Corporate
America because we're in a capitalist
country and I've been telling the
audience that if you think that you're
going to topple capitalism you're
running down the wrong road like you're
not it's it that's that's the
authoritarian view of it on the other
side now um you sent me this morning a
video speaking of gambleism and uh trust
laws which we should have Anti-Trust
laws in this country
um a lot of people don't know this
um
but the reason why your grocery prices
are so [__] high is because of
corporate gouging right and it's uh it's
not it's not real inflation it's Capital
inflation and they're doing it on
purpose now some of it some of it's real
right like the eight prices there was a
shortage so some of that some of that is
real but
yeah totally let me let me stop you
there that that is a perfect example
right a perfect example you had
Farmers out there that were putting
YouTube videos out literally getting
themselves in troubles with with the
grocery stores that they supply for they
were putting videos up saying No this is
a fiction we have eggs look behind me
this is my inventory I have eggs going
bad I cannot get these eggs out of here
because they jacked up the prices in the
stores which killed consumption
so they were sitting there making a ton
of money off of eggs and the suppliers
were like I got eggs rotten in the
warehouse man this is [__] this is
not us yeah and and that's when you
noticed egg prices tanked immediately
after that when the when you know the
hit dog squeals man when the farmers
were taking the hit and and the blame
they went
straight to social media and that's why
I love social media man I really do
that's why I really love social media
but they went to social media and they
were showing their farms and saying no
we do not have an egg shortage do not
blame this on me we had a shortage last
year
one of these videos I want to see one of
these videos
are crashing and we know that
um but there is there's more to this
story right and the reason why I bring
this up is because of the um the video
you sent me this morning from Robert
Rice you were talking about him earlier
in a different video about svb but this
this is much more at the heart of people
in this country this story that he's
going to talk about because Kroger which
is one of the largest grocery store
chains in the country and they don't
just own Kroger they own a lot of
different brands they own gerbs they own
Dylan's
um I actually I'm a Kroger customer
because one of our closest grocery
stores is a gerbs
um that that is nearby to me that we
shop at and I have I have friends that
actually have worked or worked for
Kroger as well so
um but this story is is that Kroger's
trying to buy Albertsons which is
another one of the leading biggest
market shares in these grocery chains
again Albertson's kind of the same way
they don't just own Albertsons they own
a lot of different brands because over
the last two decades and really since
the 1980s so it'd be three decades
um more and more and more of these
grocery stores these smaller chains were
eaten up by these big corporate chains
and the reason why is because there's
not a big margin in grocery there just
isn't so it's hard it's hard for a
mom-and-pop grocery store to survive in
the market with a very small market
share that's just how capitalism that's
just how markets work especially in in
today's age where big big corporate
stores uh can box out small Mom and Pops
now Robert Rice does a great video on
explaining why it is it is not such a
great thing for a chain like Kroger to
buy um a big giant like Albertson so
this is a giant buying a giant right
it's not a giant buying a small group of
stores like 12 stores or a small mom and
pop operation this is this is a giant
buying a giant go ahead yeah I've got I
got a list of this you were talking
about the brands that these stores own
Kroger owns Bakers City Market Dillons
foods for Less Foods company Fred Meyers
fries gerbs JC Foods king supers that's
another big one bananos Metro Market uh
uh
um QFC uh pick and save Ralphs rulers
Smith's Foods Albertsons own Safeway
Vons Jewel
um Acme Tom Thumb Randalls United
Supermarkets Pavilion star markets I
mean King foods that I mean it's just
every major Supermarket out there these
two own but it's even more complex I
want to tell you before you because I
want to get your opinion on this and
we'll show a bit of the video but the
reason why when someone like Kroger
Albertson goes into a regional area
because grocery stores are Regional or
have been in our country and and the
reason why is because it is grocery
um but but the reason why when
Albertsons or Kroger buys a regional
store and they keep it the same is
because they don't want the customers to
leave that store they want the store to
seem exactly the same it's just the
ownership that changes and then the
management style that changes with it
um so the customer still thinks they're
buying from the same owner that they
bought before but it's a completely
different owner they're giving their
money to someone completely different
and that that is that is a strategy is
be because the country our country is so
used to grocery being Regional that they
try to make it seem like it's still
Regional and it's going to remain the
same if Kroger does acquire Albertsons
they're not going to change all their
brands it's going to remain all the same
it's just going to be you're giving your
dollar to someone different and that is
the most important part for people and
it's and it's really complex too Tony
because it's like if this merger we know
is not a good thing but they're not
doing it because they're evil they're
not they're doing it because they're
trying to save their own asses because
they've got Market pressures on them
you've got a Walmart that owns 25
percent of the grocery market
they're the biggest they're the biggest
they're the tallest hog at the trough
Walmart they're fighting Walmart Amazon
their Distribution Systems damn they're
with them now right no well see that's
where I was going actually Amazon is not
a big major player like people think
they own one percent it's like 1.5 I
think actually now but aren't they the
fastest growing and that's what these
that's what they're really [__]
scared of see this is what's terrifying
you were talking about these stores on
the field the brick and mortar stores
remember what happened to Best Buy Best
Buy used to be it you know what I mean
they were all brick and mortar the
market changed Amazon came in they own
1.5 percent of the market but let me
give you an idea here Amazon's 1.5
percent of the market they have 42
stores 42 that's it there are 42 Amazon
freshers The Brick and Mortar brick and
mortar right Kroger has eight percent of
the market Albertsons has five percent
of the market uh between the two they
have five thousand stores five thousand
brick and mortar stores Walmart on the
overhead there yeah well they're
terrified of what what Amazon's doing
because you know that like you said
their overhead is next to nothing how do
you compete with an Amazon that is
selling all of its Dry Goods you know
dirt cheap and they can have a million
different options but I I'll give you an
example I was looking for mustard seeds
Tony mustard seeds if I go to my grocery
store I can get a little container about
this big for about five bucks I I was
looking at Amazon 25 bucks I can get a
six pound container
do you need six pounds of [__]
Mustard Seed well you know I'm thinking
about making some mustard it really was
you know I was something a little
different something I did not not yet
I've got to prove that stuff through my
wife you know what I mean she's probably
in the chat we'll find out if she's
gonna let you know
it's terrifying well you is the thing is
that because I I've been telling the
audience that look
um we're not going to be able to walk
away from capitalism this idea that
capitalism we're going to crash
capitalism we're going to crash the
economic system here and change it is
just just as dumb as the fascist on the
right thinking that we're gonna undo our
constitution we're just not gonna do
that we're not at that point in history
we're not strained to undo our economic
system or our Constitution and there is
no there is no justification for it at
this moment in time a lot of people want
to think there is but in all honesty
you're you're fighting forces that you
cannot imagine but here's the thing is
then I'm going to play this video with
Robert Reich but the thing that I think
this hurts the most is
um The Common Man and it's always when
um we get into a situation where big
money Amazon or Kroger or Albertsons
whoever this is
um you know rather Amazon has the low uh
overhead where where these big Grocers
have the high overhead I mean you look
at you just look at even Walmart stores
did you know they have triple net leases
on us almost all their stores and almost
every grocery store that you see out
there almost all of them are triple net
leases they don't actually own those
[__] buildings
um Walmart will build them Dollar
General builds them
you know a lot of these retail stores
are going and build a building in the
town and then they'll sell it to someone
who will triple net lease it to them and
the reason why is so they have less
overhead of not owning that [__]
building but you know there's a lot of
different things that happen here's
here's what I want to they do it under
shell corporations but here's the thing
is that who it affects is the common
working man right and what it's going to
do is put
um Kroger Kroger and Albertsons if they
do merge it'll put Kroger in a position
to not have to compete in some of these
markets and when they don't compete in
markets they're not just competing for
cost of goods and and the price of
grocery which that will hurt the price
of grocery because they may control it
in certain areas they may have the
entire market share in those towns or in
those areas in those markets which only
increased increases the possibility of
prices going up but the thing that
people forget is the [__] labor cost
because well I think Kroger's uh CEO
last year made 18 million bucks is what
he made
now what kind of bonuses do you think
him and his upper management are going
to receive for this merger Texas Paul
you think it's going to be you think
they're going to lose money or do you
think they're going to make money
they're going to make the executive the
only winner here is the executives in
the stores
that's right that's right everybody else
loses right the people checking out
groceries aren't going to get their
wages increased they're not going to get
more benefits they're not going to see a
bonus come because
um um because Albertson's sold out in
their shareholders got a a flood of
money right a flood of cash they're not
going to see that not only that is that
their lives their lives the only way
that they change is in these markets
when the groceries go up because let's
be honest the people who work in the
stores they buy groceries at those
stores we were talking about uh Company
Store last Friday I think
um but a lot of times when you work in
this industry and that's why unions are
so important and um the reason why gerbs
Dylan's Kroger in general all those
Brands and Albertsons are going to say
no this is good for the workers this is
good for because they want the merger
and they want the merger without
unionization on the other side
um because that's really Their Fear is
because again because the these markets
are so slim what I mean by that is the
margin on groceries believe it or not is
very very low I mean you're talking
about they're making in the one percent
range
um one or two percent but that's why
grocery prices have risen but the
margins haven't changed a lot but the
dollars have the dollars definitely have
and that's the problem that we have but
I'm going to show this video
um from Robert Rice here to explain a
little bit of this there's a
three-minute video we might play it all
but uh let's start watching here I think
your grocery bill is high now just wait
a massive corporate merger could send
skyrocketing food prices through the
stratosphere unless government sees the
deal for what it is a rotten egg
Supermarket giant Kroger is in the
process of finalizing a nearly 25
billion dollar deal to acquire its jumbo
size competitor Albertsons combining
their 5 000 supermarkets into one Mega
company corporate concentration in the
grocery Market is already a huge problem
with estimates showing that just five
companies control over 60 percent of
American Grocery sales this means less
consumer choice and more opportunity for
grocery stores to jack up prices which
they've already been doing under the
cover of inflation
let's be clear big corporations are
using the excuse of inflation to pass
price increases through to you we view a
little bit of inflation is always good
in our business we would expect to be
able to pass that through this coming
from a CEO whose recent 18 million
dollar compensation was already 679
times that of the typical Kroger
employee
what's that smell it's not a rotisserie
chicken
a taste of it um and this video is a
little longer so I'm going to retweet
this video
um and of course uh if you're not
following Robert Reich he always breaks
this down uh in a certain way now
um the FTC is still trying to approve
this merger rather they do or not I
guess that's the question my guess is
they will Texas Paul even even as rotten
as this deal may be as Robert Reich
rightly points out that this is going to
be bad for the American worker
um and and there should be maybe FTC
should make some stipulations on this
deal I don't know if they will but it
seems like this merger is gonna go
through what do you think
um you know it it it's it's damned if
you do damned if you but if you don't
because we're going to end up like I
said this is bad for everybody
um
and if it doesn't go through it's bad
also because we're going to end up we're
in late stage capitalism here Tony the
late stage capitalism is always bad
um if they don't get the merger
they're gonna die they're going to end
up starting to sell off stores they're
going to end up in that debt spiral they
may not die don't get me wrong but
there's going to be a major contraction
for them they're not going to be able to
swing with Walmart they're not going to
be able to swing with what Amazon does
in the future you know Amazon just had a
slight pause because they had their
layoffs and whatnot so they're they're
fresh expansion has has slowed to damn
near a stop for right now but when this
reorganization that Amazon's done
they're going to come out guns blazing
and and Kroger knows I mean McMullen
said we need to you know we need to we
intend to change what uh you buy at
Krogers and Albertsons that's a direct
shot over the bow of Walmart you know
they're going to turn their stores more
into Walmarts and he goes in that's a
partial quote he goes into talk about
people are going to want to buy
humidifiers people are going to want to
buy uh uh patio furniture people are
going to want you know what I mean he's
talking about expanding
they've already expanded that in some of
these smaller stores and someone brought
up in the chat and again a lot of these
brands that Kroger and Albertsons own
you don't know that Kroger and
Albertsons owns them but if you go in
and I forget the Albertson brand but
Kroger brand is Kroger Brand like if you
go into a Kroger owned store there's
going to be Kroger Brand on the shelves
and that that means it is a Kroger owned
store
um that's that's one ways that they make
more of a profit and and the ability to
pay the CEO 18 million dollars in
compensation
um but like Tony like yeah like you were
saying earlier the the profit margin in
food isn't that high right you know I
mean and and that's what they're trying
to change that's why I say it's late
stage capitalism is just a problem
they're going to try to ratchet these
margins up on the food but they're
facing a problem also it's not just the
groceries that's why this is so complex
Tony and while we've let it get to be so
bad
um you've got three companies that are
not that these stores have to deal with
you've got three soda companies that own
93 percent of the soda Market
you know and these these grocery stores
have to deal with them you've got uh
three companies that own 73 percent of
the breakfast cereal Market
and they have to deal with them I mean
people like Syria Pepsi owns 80 you know
we got March Madness coming up you want
some some dip for your chips PepsiCo
owns 88 of the dip Market
you know so it's not just the grocery
stores I mean it's these bottlenecks
keep happening at every section because
of late stage capitalism we've let these
companies buy each other and buy each
other and buy each other and buy each
other to the point where and the people
that are getting screwed or the are the
producers the guardian did a great piece
where they were talking about monopolies
always labor it's always labor that gets
screwed rather rather you're providing
the the the actual uh end product or
you're you're you're checking out
groceries or you're delivering the
groceries in a truck it's always the
labor that gets the shaft always yeah
we're talking about food right so we're
talking about Farmers or ranchers or
whatever they get 15 percent
by the time everything's done every
dollar you spend
15 goes to the farmers and ranchers and
that's going down Tony around here we've
had we've had tons of
small poultry Farmers they used to be
chicken houses all over the place out
here they're gone Tony they're gone they
just can't make it anymore because the
the grocery stores tell them you'll sell
us eggs at this price and they're like
well we can't raise eggs at that price
and they're like
[__] off we've got somebody else that
will you know I mean
it's it's bad all-around bad and and you
know I'm going back into the banking
crisis maybe we should take
um more of a stance and the FTC should
take more of a stance and protect the
depositors not the investors not the
management of these companies and say
hey look Kroger in Albertsons we
understand that you're going to go under
and you're gonna have to break up your
company and start selling off your
assets
um if you if you don't make this merger
but maybe just maybe
um we should do that and and I mean but
all you're doing is laying the
groundwork for Walmart and Amazon to
take the entire market so you know it it
like you said damned if you do and
damned if you don't so
um and and what do you do about your
dollar that's the other question because
that's your vote that that truly is the
the Democratic part of capitalism is
your dollar but a lot of times
um your democracy doesn't go very far
when there's only one grocery that is
available uh for your dollar so it's a
problem
and we have to have serious
conversations about it not just not just
a big huge swapping oh well we gotta get
rid of this or we gotta get rid of that
so um I agree that it's very complex
it's hard to um you know undo this
fabric that we've built
um of capitalism in this late stage
and it's two different philosophies Tony
I keep saying we have to elect Democrats
because I mean you know who's brokering
this deal for Krogers and Albertsons
You're gonna laugh when I tell you John
Boehner
I am I'm not kidding he worked he would
he left he went to work for patent Boggs
and he is the guy that is ushering this
deal through he's the one that's that's
greasing the tracks he's delivering he's
delivering the merger from the FTC
because he's exactly exactly and a lot
of people don't know this but John
Boehner would know exactly who's on the
FDC and exactly who who needs to be who
needs to be on board with this to get
this merger accomplished
um and that's why he's at the helm not
because he knows grocery I mean he he he
used to sweep the floor he used to sweep
the floor is dead
I know his experience is sweeping floors
and bars has nothing to do with his
experience of uh of uh brokering uh
murder no but being speaker of the house
and making shaking friends with hands
with lobbyists sure the hell did didn't
he well he he knows he knows like you
said he knows he's who the grease the
wheels with over there
um I I wanna I'm gonna jump stories here
so I'm glad we got to talk about that
that
um I think that's an important story
that no one's really gonna have their
their uh their thumb on because of all
the crazy [__] going on and boy do we
have some crazy [__] have you have you
watched this [__] video of Grandpa
Poopypants let me see if I can find this
some [__] he has lost his mind
um
he's talking about a cognitive test he
wants all presidential candidates to
take a cognitas Texas ball I don't think
he's aware that we still mock him for
this I don't I know does he not know
that does he not know that now again I
want to point out how dark this is
getting the lighting sucks the makeup's
horrible I don't even know if the guy
has pants on anymore this is really this
is getting man this is getting [__]
ridiculous
um with these videos that he's trying to
come out with and he's trying to get
uh more and more hitler-like and it's um
and and I'm going to show you a tweet
from Ben Shapiro he's really upset that
we're comparing them to Nazis but I'll
show you why we're doing that because
they are Nazis but listen listen to
Grandpa here
um talk about uh cognitive test as if he
has any cognitive ability he needs to be
bragging about in my mind anybody
running for the office of President of
the United States
the United States the president of the
United States oh my God this is so
ridiculous I can't even believe I have
to play this Texas Ball but here we are
this is what we have to do he's freaking
out over there uh let's let's continue
agreed to take a full and complete
mental competency test
simultaneously or before with the
announcement that he or she is running
and likewise but to a somewhat lesser
extent agreed to a test which would
prove that you are physically capable of
doing the job as what the [__] is he
rambling on about
person Man car television
treason
Russia Putin Putin
oh my God this guy listen this is so he
wants to have I I guess what he's
proposing here is that we have a
physical and a competency test for the
presidency of the United States which he
would fail
um watched him walking down a ramp we
know the guy has lost his [__]
marbles really honestly he hasn't lost
his marbles his [__] marbles packed
their [__] and they left they're like
get your [__] Harry where the [__] we're
getting the [__] out of here I just he's
a [__] sociopath man
I mean he could not this is not this is
not drunk Ronnie Jackson doing this if
they established this which I have no
problem with do it dude [__] do it
right but how the hell is that sociopath
fat ass gonna squeeze through the crack
of being called mentally competent not
gonna happen I have no I I mean the
oh it's hard to imagine
um here's here's another part and I
don't know if this is a clip of the same
video but here it is here's another part
where he's talking about you gotta you
gotta elect him or we're all dead he
really thinks we're all gonna die if we
don't Enlighten him let's listen this
time in the history of our country World
War III is looming like never before in
the very dark and murky background lack
of leadership is solely responsible for
this unprecedented Danger
to our beautiful USA and likewise to the
world itself
hopeless Joe Biden is leading us into
Oblivion we cannot let it happen we have
to take back the White House or our
country is doomed
thank you very much
[Music]
he's like our country's game thank you
very much thank you thank you thank you
very much now he's talking about world
war three which I don't know the last
time I checked Texas ball this is the
last time I checked and it's been a
little bit
um the last time I checked our military
is not engaged in an active War anywhere
you know I have troops on the ground we
don't have an active War Congress hasn't
been at all even interested in declaring
war on anyone so I don't know where this
war is that they're talking about I
think what he's saying is because we're
defending democracy in Ukraine against
Russia I think by supplying them
Weaponry which it's not just us
supplying them Weaponry so that must
mean all these other countries out there
that are defending democracy against the
Russian forces which are not supposed to
be in a Sovereign Nation of Ukraine that
democracy
um I think that's what he's trying to
say but we don't we do I maybe maybe I'm
just off my rocker here and maybe I miss
the news that we have ground troops
somewhere have I missed that what's
what's going on here
we've got a few volunteers that went
over to Ukraine but that's it I mean we
do not have ground troops on the ground
in Ukraine we just don't I mean but we
we are training we are training the [__]
out of and we're training the Polish
also uh we're bumping up I don't know if
you know Poland bought about 40 F 35 uh
f-35s we're bumping that up as fast as
we can because I guarantee you man that
Russia has lost and this is what's got
Grandpa Poopypants so
in a tizzy is because Russia has lost I
want you to think about this they cannot
defeat Ukraine
Wagner's just disappearing they they've
got a month's worth of men a little over
a month's worth of men left that's it
and and they're done they're out of this
fight they because they cannot conscript
uh criminals anymore they can't they're
done
forgive me but if let's imagine for a
second that Ukraine suddenly starts to
look like it's losing instead of just
whipping Russia's ass left and right
let's imagine they start losing what
happens
Poland jumps in Poland is not going to
fight the Russians in Poland no they're
going to fight him in the [__]
Ukraine right they don't want to cross
over their border yeah I mean this is
like this brains didn't ukrainians
didn't want Russia in their [__]
country right and and you've got I mean
the the minute it looks like Russia
hasn't and they don't they don't they're
running they ever they're running out of
ammunition which makes me laugh because
you got all the old YouTube videos of
Billy Bob buying buying Uh Russian ammo
that you know was sold all over the damn
world because people were stealing ammo
and selling it everywhere
um now Russia has no freaking ammo
Poland has better tanks and its
inventory than Russia
right I mean literally if it comes down
to a tank battle they're going to have
better aircraft than Russia well and the
other the other thing that I think um is
important here is Poland is a NATO State
um that's the other thing that is very
significant uh well you know talking
about that Tony let me just head this
off where they're going with oh that
means World War III no it doesn't
the opposite is the opposite of that
yeah because the Article 5 guarantees
are for defense right if Poland jumps in
willingly we'll support them we'll we'll
sell them [__] we'll give them [__] but
we're not going we're not bound by
NATO's Article 5 treaty uh
to go in and fight with Poland because
they jump into a fight
that's what people don't seem to
understand is this is not world war
three this is just Russia straight up
getting its ass kicked right well and
and the Article 5 is to prevent uh and
the NATO states with the article five
powers are are designed to prevent a
World War Not to cause it this is all
ridiculous and
um we thought that there was going to be
article four actually instituted when
some missiles landed in Poland you
remember that we were on the air when
that happened
um and a lot of people were terrified of
that here's another video of Grandpa
um this is a little different this is
more of him talking about um his
problems here at home and he thinks that
it's racism against him I [__] you not
he thinks the reason why he has legal
troubles is because prosecutors are
racist against him I don't know if he
thinks that you can be racist against
orange people or not I'm not really sure
what he's saying here but let's let's
take a listen and see what what
Grandpa's um
um delusional about crooked Democrat
prosecutors many of them racists in
Reverse they are absolute racists so
they're they're racist in Reverse uh
Texas ball so what they're saying is the
reason why they're brosky isn't because
he committed crimes it's because they're
racist in reverse and he's white that's
what it is
Republicans are still as big actually
here in Texas actually Nationwide the
Republicans I don't know this is a big
thing for them
um I don't know if you've been following
the Dei stuff the diversity equity and
inclusion stuff yeah they they are
that's their new CRT the Dei yeah yeah
is the next big enemy the CRT was in
2020 now it's the Dei
we've got Texas A M here which is a
conservative run uh Republican it's
where all the Republican broken toys go
for a job around here after they leave
office they immediately jumped on this
Dei as racism even though there are no
quotas in Dei it's not affirmative
action it's it's it but they're this is
the name every corporation this is the
narrative every group every University
including Fox News has Dei protocols
they have them yeah it is a thing and
the reason why is because of capitalism
because it is hard to Market yourself as
a group or a university or an
institution or a corporation if you're
not having Dei in protocols inside your
Human Resources it's just it's just not
possible and the reason why is because
we're such a diverse nation that you
can't listen you're not going to have
all white companies all white
universities it's just not going to
happen the diversity of this nation and
now Liberty University you know some of
these religious organizations that's why
they they're all balls deepens
well that's why their balls deep into
Christian national uh Christian
nationalism is because with their
religious exemption they can start to um
to really white it up if you know what I
mean but let's let's finish what Grandpa
poopy pants is scared of here because he
tells us what he's scared of Texas ball
let's listen
are trying to steal a second
presidential election they did it in
2020 and we're not going to let them do
it again in 2024 make America great
again so they're scared they're going to
prosecute him and stop his presidential
run uh to become dictator of the United
States of trump
um is that's what it seems like to me
maybe uh maybe I'm off my rocker is he's
always projecting and he's projecting
that these prosecutors are getting close
which
um we know Michael Cohen is a
contributor and he has a podcast here on
the minus touch Network and we're a
partner with the minus touch and you
post on minus touch as well but we know
yesterday he he testified in front of
the Manhattan DA's grand jury for three
full hours which is significant and not
only did he do it for three four hours
he's back again today which only tells
me and gives me the signal that the
grand jury is very interested in hearing
what Michael Cohen has to say I think
that's pretty significant
yeah because you know reminding folks of
grand jury is not a hearing where you
have both sides argue it out in front of
the no this is the prosecution laying
out their case you know trying trying
you know trying to get an indictment you
know this is not this is not like what
you see on TV with trials a grand jury
is just them presenting their case this
is the if they want to hear more about
this that's always bad news bad news for
whoever they're trying to indict
absolutely now I want to show you um
because since Trump's in the news
DeSantis desantos I've been calling him
desantos meatball Ronnie tiny D
um I'm trying out all kinds of nicknames
for him I like the [__] meatball
thing I don't care if you hate Trump
he's got some good nicknames he does
meatball fits that [__] uh Ben
Shapiro is really worried
um that um people are gonna paint uh
Trump and De Santos as Hitler I wonder
why hmm uh he he tweets amazing to see
all the people who say Trump was Hitler
now swiveling to decrying to Santas
they're basically looking for excuse to
back Biden and it's perfectly obvious
and I said yes yes little Ben it is
perfectly obvious that Trump and mimar
are leaning into Hitler you [__]
bonehead the reason why we're saying
this stuff is because they're doing this
stuff that's why we're saying it and
it's perfectly obvious that obviously
people are going to choose Biden over
someone who is trying to emulate Hitler
and Nazi Germany yeah I think that's
going to be the case
um Ben Shapiro is a [__] idiot I
don't know if people know this a lot of
people think a lot of people think oh
well he's a great commentator he has
great ideas he's a [__] idiot he is
not a smart [__] the reason why
Ben Shapiro is uh who he is is because
he's a silver spoon son of a [__] who
failed at Hollywood he [__] failed so
he's taken it out on the rest of us by
and his wife's um dry ass his dap his
wife's dap I don't know you know if you
know about that look I'm just gonna say
it this is a guy this is how brilliant
brilliant this guy is he went on
his own show and said he couldn't get
his wife wet right well he claimed that
she said that wet ass [__] does not
exist and I mean maybe it doesn't in
their household maybe it doesn't I don't
know yeah I mean I would have to you
know do a consultation with
him I'm just saying that Ben Shapiro
dries up the room when he walks in it
um but here's the here's the craziest
part to meet Texas Paul that he is
claiming that we are somehow we are the
ones who are making De Santos and and
Trump
Nazis and Hitler somehow it's us doing
this it could Texas ball it couldn't be
it could be that the daily wire itself
who Ben Shapiro started who's the
[__] founder in the head of is
pushing this anti-trans anti-drag show
[__] agenda on this country to try
that Stoke culture wars you [__] and and
Michael moles who is a [__] host on
The Daily wire going to CPAC saying he
wants to eradicate transgender people I
don't care what [__] phrasing he used
he wants to eradicate transgender people
I don't give a [__] what you're saying
and over the weekend Texas Paul their
agenda is playing out in Ohio at a drag
show and Republicans Republicans dressed
in costumes matching costumes and
matching uniforms showed up with Nazi
Flags to protest test this drag show
here I I'm not making this [__] up this
isn't me making it up this is Ben
Shapiro's supporters this is Michael
Knowles supporters this is daily wire
audience members dressing up in Nazi
uniforms caring Nazi Flags to go carry
out their agenda to eradicate a group of
[__] our countrymen watch
[Music]
oh my God
so excuse me excuse me when Trump and
desantos and the daily wire are on the
side of Nazis that is not my [__]
problem I don't control that you support
and also neo-nazis and other Republican
groups like neo-nazis like white lines
man are like the brown boys and Patriot
run front support your [__] agenda to
eradicate a group of our countrymen I
don't know if I lost Texas ball or not I
can't tell he's Frozen
I think I lost him you might have to
come out and go back um you go out and
go back in Texas Ball but the the point
is this is that this is not our problem
Ben Shapiro that we are comparing or
that we have the ability to call Trump
or desantos Nazis it's not it's not our
problem
it's not our problem and I think I did
lose Texas ball he'll come back in he'll
come back in he just must have lost
connection just a bit so it's not our
problem Ben
it's not our problem when you're amazed
to see all the people who said Trump was
Hitler they're leaning into it you dumb
[__] and the reason why they're
leaning into it is because their
constituency is buying your fascist
[__] on your [__] Network you you
sad sack of garbage
so yeah so yeah
is it going to be that um people are
going to basically look for an excuse to
vote for Biden and the excuse being that
it's pretty obvious that you Trump De
Santos and all manga Republicans are
[__] Nazis yeah I would say I would
say their little Ben that that's gonna
be the case
that's gonna be the [__] case you
piece of [__] trash
uh sorry I didn't mean to um get too
crazy there um we're gonna wait for
Texas Paul uh here I want to uh while
we're waiting for Texas Paul to re-enter
the room
uh he must have connection problems here
he'll get back with us
um here's here's the thing uh about uh
the band and a lot of people were
wondering now that we have an audience
here I want to let you know that we were
on a seven day suspension uh on our main
Channel and we went over to the up wires
channel uh so do me a favor if you're on
the up wire right now and go go follow
that And subscribe to that and you can
find the upward the upwire.com the
upwire.com you can go uh find that and
also
um follow their Twitter as well so go to
the upwire.com follow their Twitter and
subscribe to the YouTube channel super
important I want to thank you for all
your support and a lot of people wanted
a um a promo code for the [__] em hats
if you go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com you'll just
scroll down a bit there's the hat store
there you just click on the hat store
use the promo code podcast or the promo
code hats10 promo code podcast or promo
codes hats tending you can get 10 off
all your your entire purchase there [__]
em hats
um at the at the hat store so go to the
Tony michaels.com scroll down to the hat
store and use the promo code podcast or
the promo code hats10 and you get 10 off
your entire purchase there looks like we
have uh Texas Paul back here uh what's
your take on a little Ben Shapiro here
in the Nazis there in Ohio not Texas
sorry about that Tony my internet
service providers having problems I'm
losing all internet for there briefly
and it comes right back I apologize for
that folks no problem Ben Shapiro
uh this guy is just just I want you to
think about this I mean what are we
doing what are we doing we're sitting
there watching these people we're
watching tiny D down in Florida and
we're saying okay he's attacking trans
people check you know he he's attacking
corporations check he's trying to
initiate a uh a religious takeover of
schools check all of this stuff happened
all of this stuff happened
in Nazi Germany and all we're doing is
sitting here saying this is what you
just did it is just like them when you
walked out of out of libraries carrying
books that is exactly what the Nazis did
and they the and they took the same
exact books off the shelves right you
know and we're the ones making them
Nazis no we're just we're just pointing
out this is what you're doing right
we're just pointing out that you are
because you you are and Ben Shapiro's
mad that we're that's that's what he's
really upset about Texas ball more than
anything here is he's upset that we are
pointing out the and he says it perfect
it's perfectly obvious yes it is
perfectly obvious that you guys are
Nazis and that is the reason why people
out there in the country are gonna look
for an excuse to vote for Biden I I
would on in Texas Paul the more this
goes on the fight between Trump and
desantos because that's the election
cycle that we're actually in right now
as the Republican primary a lot of
people don't understand it a lot of the
mainstream media is talking about if Joe
Biden is going to have a challenger and
all that nonsense get the [__] out of
here that's the 2024 election Joe
Biden's going to be the nominee there's
no way the incumbent Democrat with a
record like his is not going to be the
nominee people are [__] stupid if you
think there's any chance even if you
hate Biden even if you hate him and you
think he's old or whatever there's no
chance whatsoever none zero chance that
Joe Biden will not be the nominee Bank
on it now now that you know that fact
now that I've told you that truth you
know that the only race that matters
right now especially to people in the
pro-democracy Coalition is the
Republican primary and we must get Ron
desantos and Grandpa Poopypants to
Cheeto dusk you and honor Donald Trump
to fight it out and to out Hitler each
other and the reason why is because the
more they the more they go balls deep
into fascism the more it is going to
give people out there who who would
otherwise vote for republicans in a in a
presidential election or are likely to
switch sides or why voted for Biden this
time but I'll vote for this person that
time I voted for Trump the first time
then I voted you're only giving those
people more of an excuse and I believe
we're getting into the margins of 14 to
16 million uh in the margin where where
Joe Biden is going to beat Donald Trump
because it is clear that Ron desantos is
not ready to run for president and not
only that he clearly does not understand
Trump's cult like Trump understands that
yeah I mean people I always say this
Tony people don't vote it's just a
political fact it's been around forever
I didn't coin this there's been around
forever people don't vote to say thank
you people vote to say [__] you that's
what they do so all the great stuff that
Biden is doing and this and the other
let's throw that out boom it's gone
that's not what's going to happen in
this next election it's going to be who
can pull the [__] out to piss that to
point out that pisses people off and
think about the freaking ads they're
giving us Tony
think about think about what the ads are
going to look like in this next election
we're going to need to destroy these
people you're damn right and now and not
only Shapiro knows it not only that um
Ben Shapiro knows that we're getting
louder right
um liberal media is coming is coming uh
and it is going to compete with
conservative media they've had the
absolute [__] Monopoly on Independent
style media in this country and and
they've all in the way that they've done
it is to pin up the [__] the the the
mainstream media some sort of liberal
arm of the [__] country in the
government which is not [__] true at
all that's all [__] and if you don't
believe it come here and listen to me
bash the [__] mainstream media
because they're derelict in their duty
to democracy trying not to look biased
when just because the truth looks biased
doesn't mean it still ain't the [__]
truth and it's ridiculous I'll show you
an example of this I'll show you an
example Texas well here is right wing
Media Fox News who's currently in a
[__] defamation lawsuit with Dominion
the state in New York has paved the way
for smart manic to [__] sue the pants
off Rupert Murdoch for almost three
billion dollars here
um I said the other day that Rupert
Murdoch will survive this and Fox News
will I think Fox News will but God damn
if you start to rack up uh three four
six six ten billion dollars
um and Rupert Murdoch uh follows by the
by the grace of like what Alex Jones
fell by uh you're gonna you're gonna see
that that um it's gonna damage them
um very badly but they're not going to
go away it's gonna survive but listen to
Brian Gilman here he's read they wrote
this [__] Texas ball they I can't even
[__] believe this he is reading this
off a page they wrote this for him
listen to this so I can listen to this
since you went and visited East
Palestine uh stopped having lunch with
white supremacists stop having lunch
with white supremacist
they [__] it they're talking about Trump
they're talking about Trump are you
[__] kidding me so they're like oh
well he went and visited the place where
he his his [__] his policy just
destroyed the town he went and passed
down house hats and bought him Big Macs
and now the guy stopped eating lunch
with white supremacists so what what
Brian kill me what what is this is this
a good thing or a bad thing let's listen
uh and it has got a very disciplined
message according to the Emerson poll
he's got 73 percent uh uh approval
rating among uh Republicans
so stupid again this is why I don't
[__] uh give my audience polls and
[__] because they're all just [__]
nonsense anyways that they want an
outcome to a poll and they do a poll to
get that outcome right I mean that's how
these polls are working that's how it's
operating at this point
um but I find it funny that Fox News is
now trying to sell Donald Trump as
discipline because he's not having
dinner with Nazis
that's literally that's what they're
doing Texas Paul
yeah it's it's pathetic I mean it's
really pathetic uh and and he's going to
they know he's going to he's gonna it's
not like he's gonna yeah but he's not
gonna stay on message he's not gonna
trump it Trump is going to be the
disaster that Trump is the problem with
that they have is that it's getting
really stale
it's getting really stale people are
really getting tired of this when you
get as loud and obnoxious as as Tiny D
has and As Trump has people get tired of
it you know and when it comes to
election time you're going to have two
choices you're going to have Joe Biden
who they're going to try to make a bunch
of [__] up about I mean like they just
the other day Tony they tried to say did
you know Tony uh that Biden uh stopped
Drilling in the Arctic well that's not
true that's just not true they put
leases out nobody bought them so they
took the leases back
that's all they have to run on is [__]
that they try to make up we on the other
hand really have footage of [__] coming
out their mouths and we're going to beat
the living [__] out of them with it well
they're just not used to that I think I
think um them going balls deep on the
word woke is actually turning
um the country against them they don't
understand it because what they're doing
is they're taking a word that means
black because that's what it means to
them you're turning the country black
it's woke it's black people this black
people that that's what they mean by
woke
um but when they're trying when they're
really trying hard to take the word woke
which to them means black people or the
hard R inward right if they're trying to
take that and reappropriate it to the
lgbtq community the country isn't seeing
the correlation there right they they're
starting to lose the plot and they're
starting to lose the plot line by
getting in these wars over this word and
just saying a word that they think gets
their base riled up over and over and
over again like like this [__] I'm
gonna play this clip again because we
were talking about this earlier with s
uh svb and James Comer the [__] the
chairman of the house oversight
committee one of the most important
[__] committees to make sure our
government is [__] operating the way
that it's supposed to goes on Fox News
and calls the SB svb crisis the reason
why is because of wokism well listen to
this
and then we see now coming out that they
were one of the most woke banks in uh
their in their quest for uh the ESG type
type policy and investing you know this
could be a trend and there are
consequences for bad Democrat policy and
I think we need to keep an eye on all
the the banking sector right now and it
failed miserably 24 hours later when all
the banks are secured the depositors are
secure there's not a run on banks the
market the market today is is still at
32 000 damn near right now it's up 135
points currently today as I'm looking at
it on my watch I mean this is all
[__] nonsense it's all [__] lies
and I mean everyone thought that they
were going to lose their Investments
yesterday or and the day before because
of wokism and it's not true it just if
their message [__] fell flat they
were praying that SVU would cause a bank
collapse and these Bank it would have
what they call the domino effect and the
domino effect would kick in and when
that happened when that happened the
domino effect kicked in then they could
blame it on Biden and they could say
it's wokeism see and then they could pin
wokism on anything they want not just
black people which is what they want now
what they're saying not just the lgbtq
but Bank collapses Bank collapses are
because people are woke to social issues
that you [__] caught shouldn't be
killing black people that we shouldn't
be eradicating our countrymen because of
how they identify you people are [__]
dumb if you think that the svb had
anything to do with our society making
sure that people have Liberty you are a
bonehead
um sorry I didn't mean to get too much
on a ramp but there you go
no but you're you're you know Steve
daines he heads the nrsc the national
Republican senatorial committee
um he came out and he told Republicans
stop saying this [__] stop saying
because they know they jumped the shark
when when you started talking about Bank
collapses and whatnot and and tying the
word woke to it he knows they jumped the
shark he's like this is not a joke to
people this this makes us look stupid
you know because these are real issues
that people really care about right what
you're saying is you're saying is is
that they just made another excuse for
because they got all kinds of ways that
they look stupid I mean there's just all
kinds of ways are you saying that that
that they're just coming up with new
ways is that what you're saying because
it feels like no what I'm saying what
I'm saying is that that they're
panicking they're figuring out just how
stupid I mean think about every time you
see somebody come up one of these
Republicans come up and say the word
woke how stupid how stupid do they look
you know and and Steve Danes who's whose
job it is to get to get Republicans
elected is saying stop saying this [__]
stop saying it because they know their
message went stale they were too stupid
for too long about too many serious
issues and they are fools they have
always been fools but usually in a time
of a crisis you had a couple members
that you know Mitt Romney you know you
would have had somebody like a Mitt
Romney that would have stood up and
spoke sensibly and this that and the
other well they've made Mitt Romney a
freaking joke in their caucus he can't
talk to their Folks at all and that's
what Steve daines is saying is we're
screwed folks you have been fools for so
long shut the hell up this is a serious
crisis you're making us look like we're
cheering this because you're freaking
cheering this you're being idiots well
and what and what the um what the people
who buy that wokeism [__] and they're
like yeah De Santos is war on wokeism
like and he went balls deep on woke and
he can't back out of it now descent
that's why desantos will not run I don't
believe you I hope he does I hope he
gets in the race but there's not gonna
be room for him to run because because
desantos went all in on the word wokeism
now what a lot of people don't know is
Congress got together Congress got
together the other day on this SB svb
and
uh they the yelling and the uh FDIC
stepped in but they told Congress stop
[__] saying stop [__] saying the
[__] that's gonna cause an economic
collapse they said it to Congress people
on an emergency Zoom call and the reason
why is because these [__] [__]
were out there on [__] Twitter and
and they were they were trying to stoke
a bank collapse to blame it on Biden
when it wouldn't be Biden's fault or or
anything to do with Joe Biden it has
nothing to do with him not a goddamn
thing it just has to do with the
deposits that were in this bank and the
size of those deposits and the [__]
depositors got scared and went made a
run on it and which can cause a domino
effect in other Community Banks and
that's what they were trying to prevent
I'm looking for a um there's a
congressman in I believe North Carolina
forgetting his name uh he did a video on
this and he actually talks about the
meeting he talks about the um
um and I didn't [__] retweet it I
don't know why he talks about the
meeting that they had this this
emergency
um Zoom meeting and what it was is for
the actual narrative and to stop [__]
saying that these banks are going to
collapse because you're making it worse
you're giving people less confidence
when what you're saying is all [__]
when the FDIC and Janet Yellen said
we're going to protect depositors and
they took it to auction fast I mean they
were they were to auction in less than
72 hours once the FDIC took over right
am I wrong about that or was it within
79.
the weekend it crashed on a Friday
Sunday they were they had already they
already had buyers for for the asset and
that's what's so that's what the it was
the meeting you're talking about is it
was actually the Republican caucus it
was a republican only caucus got
together on this and had an emergency
meeting because you had the idiots out
there running their mouths that garnered
so much of our time and so so much of
the space that we're saying things that
that Republicans didn't want to be
blamed for literally Fox News calling
for runs on banks they were Steve daines
was the one in that meeting that told
them shut your damn mouth stop saying
things that are untrue about these Banks
because you're asking you know because
svb the the truth is the narrative is
and the truth the narrative coincide
that bank didn't need to die
it didn't need it needed some more
regulation it needed an infusion of
funds but it did not need to die and
there are other Banks out there that are
in this exact same situation the Janet
Yellen has her hands on that she is
saving those Banks she is making sure
that the the depositors in those Banks
and I say depositors I just don't mean
your average everyday person I'm talking
about companies that use these Banks to
make payroll
you know I'm talking about I'm talking
about Etsy Etsy when when svb collapsed
Etsy used svb to pay its vendors
you know I mean and then you've got
these Republicans that are saying oh run
on Banks and and that it was wokeness
that caused us and said nobody wanted to
hear that stupidity nobody and then you
had actually especially the depositors
and the people who relied on the
depositors to get them their [__]
money uh I got some breaking news here
it looks like it's just coming in from
NBC News I want uh President Carter was
trending uh he has not passed yet he is
on hospice uh you know but the breaking
news is is that um President Biden has
revealed that former uh President Jimmy
Carter who has entered Hospice Care at
his home last month after a series of
Hospital states has asked him to deliver
his eulogy um we know Jimmy Carter
um in his 90s is is on hospice and in
his his final days of his life uh but he
apparently has asked his friend uh Joe
Biden the the current president United
States uh to deliver his eulogy and his
funeral now which is more indication
that um we're actually when just happens
um which I expect with hospice we're
probably going to have Jimmy Carter's
funeral soon when this happens
um Texas Paul there's a lot of things
that are going to shift in this country
number one this brings the modern era of
presidents
um up to I think George H.W bush and
Bill Clinton because well the the oldest
not the oldest but the the the long ago
serving president is not going to be
Jimmy Carter it's going to be Bill
Clinton in the early 90s
um so our modern our thoughts of modern
presidency move from uh JFK and
post-world War II up to the 1980s and
the 1990s I believe
um that's a huge shift the other thing
that's going to be significant here in
the news is who is not invited to this
funeral
um generally speaking there will be
presidents there and president uh George
W bush will be there uh it looks like
Joe Biden is going to deliver the eulogy
uh who's uh is a friend of Jimmy Carter
but also President Bill Clinton will be
there but there will be and President
Obama but there will be a significant
um disinvite uh to the fascist and the
person who is trying to destroy our
country from the Carter family I believe
um and it will and and I think it's
going to speak louder than what the
Silence of the words will be so
um and the Texas ball has to take a
break so let me let me go um
he's got to take a break here
um so we we have news there from
um
um but Jimmy Carter has asked president
uh Jill Biden to deliver his eulogy I
saw Jimmy Carter president Carter
trending so I wanted to make sure uh
what was going on that there wasn't um
Mighty Librarians is Trump isn't invited
uh yeah well I mean I think that's going
to be a significant
um turn of events that him being a
former president he's not invited yeah
so
um let's see there's some more Liz
Cheney's trending as well let me see
what the um the news is on Liz Cheney
I'm sure it's just
um just more beating back
um here's a here's a statement from Liz
Cheney Republicans against trumpism it
looks like just a few hours ago because
you you know that the Republicans the
Nazis in the house the Republican Nazis
in that our house representatives are
trying to have a new January 6th select
committee so that they can have more
hearings on what the what the
alternative facts are uh like Tucker
Carlson tried to paint last week and
failed
um but Liz Janey said if House GOP wants
new Jan six hearings Bring It On Let's
replay every witness and all the
evidence from last year but this time
those members who sought Pardons and or
hid from subpoenas should sit on the
Deus so they can be confronted on live
television with an unsalable Evidence
yes I actually believe this too Texas
ball do you think we should have more
January 6 hearings that the Republicans
can control because we know we know from
last few weeks Texas as well they suck
at this they [__] suck at this what
do you think
get on mute there
yeah absolutely I I am loving all of
these hearings especially if they can
run it out of the house with little
Jimmy Jordan oh yeah I hope they put him
in charge of this either that or this
guy here's Paula gozar
um being asked by the Gateway pundit
which is a right-wing [__] far right
Nazi rag
um let's let's listen to him ask
um Paul goes are about Prosecuting
January 6th hearing members where they
go same with Liz Cheney is there a
chance that you guys could prosecute
certain members of Congress Congress or
former members of Congress over the
January 6th I I would not uh leave it
just that I think there's also military
that are involved right and I think that
there are you know heads have to roll uh
Texas Paul there are probably going to
be members of Congress prosecuted for
January 6. there are probably there were
there there was [__] afoot in the
military and if you watched if you
watched any in any of the January 6
hearings Paul gozar would [__] know
that now it's all projection it's all
projection from Paul goes are here he's
telling us the truth but he's trying to
project the truth not on himself and his
members and the Republican party and
Trump and those who tried to help him
commit a coup the Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup that is on January 6th but he's
trying to project it on Liz Cheney
and Adam kinzinger and and as if those
people were the ones that were trying to
overturn an election as if the
Democratic caucus wanted to make sure to
stymie the [__] the certification of
the results so Jill Biden couldn't be
president this is [__] dumb logic
it's more of them losing the plot and
I'm all here for it for them to keep
talking about this stupid [__] and I
hope they do a January 6 hearing just
like last week when Tucker Carlson
released his stupid footage and now
we're talking more about January 6 again
they're only forcing the issue for
Americans to think about this which is
bad for them because they're the
traitors
yeah I mean and did you did you see the
filing by the doj it's now the matter of
court record this Tucker Carlson crap is
is a matter of court record with the
doj
really hammering them on this being
fictitious [__] because you had the
proud boys who are being prosecuted
remember they're flipping up guys
they're flipping up they're not they're
done with the prosecution right well and
that's another significant thing you
bring up the proud boys they're seeking
Donald Trump to actually testify in
their trial because what the proud boys
are alleging is that he directed them to
do it
they actually tried to to
say enter into evidence this Tucker
Carlson Ivan Carlson [__] as
evidence and the doj just took a switch
took him out back and beat the crap out
of him for being stupid because the
exact same footage that Ivan Carlson has
the defendants have
they have had this all along this is not
exculpable exculpatory evidence in fact
the doj said this is inculpatory
evidence this makes you look more guilty
well when we went through that on the
show how this makes them look guilty
um just because Tucker Carlson frames up
30 seconds and racks up a few rolls of
30 seconds and says lies into his
microphone as an overture of the of the
footage that we can see with our [__]
eyes I mean he he claimed that the
Capitol Police let him in the building
while he was playing tape of the [__]
Q Anon Shaman Joker Joseph is it Joseph
chansley whatever the [__] that guy's
name is coming in the building through a
broken door that they kicked in I mean
this you can't make this [__] up but
they don't give a [__] because it fits
their bias and Tucker Carlson is doing
nothing but profiting off lies here but
it's not going to work in court it won't
work because it's not the [__] truth
and that and that is the thing that we
have to keep pushing here is is the
truth and I think I you know I I agree
with Liz Cheney on very little right
there's not much I agree with that
[__] fascist on because don't get it
twisted she's a [__] fascist too I
don't know if you know Cheney and the
Cheney family
um but Darth Vader and Darth Vader Jr
are not our allies in democracy but what
I will tell you is I do agree with her
on the fact that yes having more
hearings I can't I can't even tell you
how [__] how delicious it would be to
watch Lauren bobert try to question a
witness on January 6th how [__]
delicious it would be for Marjorie
Taylor green to try to say the word
billions as many times as she can
questioning a [__] wit that expert
witness on January 6. it would be I mean
it would just be fantastic I don't know
exactly how many how many views we would
get but it would it would get us a lot
of you sticks as well
and just imagine this is Kevin McCarty
this is what you get with Kevin McCarthy
he is weak and stupid could you imagine
Nancy Pelosi
being I mean if the roles were were
completely reversed we were in bizarroy
world and the roles were completely
reversed could you imagine Nancy Pelosi
allowing these morons
to re-bring this issue up to to rehash
to relitigate all this when we have all
of the footage
you know we know we saw Josh Hawley
running down the hall you know after
standing out front talking like a tough
guy yeah and then you see him in the
hallway
you know what I mean we have Leah let's
let's do that again Tony let's let's run
through all that again freaking morons I
mean they are politically morons they're
morally bankrupt they're just this whole
thing is just I hate it for my country
but as a Democrat I'm like
you know I mean this just doesn't get
any better you know
I I I just I'm watching this and
sometimes I just have to like sit in
silence and just
wow these these Republicans are trying
to put me out of a job I mean they're
just kicking themselves in the nuts man
right well the commentary is easy with
these [__] apparently there's some news
coming in uh here so there's some
breaking news uh I guess a Russian
fighter jet forced down a U.S Air Force
drone over the Black Sea now after
demanding its uh propeller damaging its
Propel excuse me U.S official has
confirmed um so it looks like uh Russia
is trying to um shoot down our uh our
drones
and it looks like
it was over the Black Sea is what
they're saying
um so there's some breaking news there
we'll have to follow that to see what
what leads into that um Black Sea is
trending on um Twitter right now because
of that and let's see if I can find any
more news on it again the the news is
that a Russian uh jet has uh strikes an
American surveillance drone uh forcing
it down over the Black Sea so um it's
not a balloon it's an actual drone it's
a surveillance drone and they've done
that and it's this news is breaking in
the last 20 minutes or so
um all they have all they have left I
mean Russia is so done all they have
left to save themselves is to try to to
Galvanize this into a war against us
it's it's the only thing they have left
and Joe Biden is going to say that drone
was cheap send up another one you know
yeah but it's yeah but is is it is it
really I mean you know to push back just
a bit is it in there is it in Vladimir
Putin's best interest to draw us into
this War I mean really honestly it's I I
don't know that it's in his best
interest I mean I think I think uh
Vladimir Putin is at his end of days
here and he's going to eat an ammo
sandwich
um probably sometime in this year and
and the longer he continues uh this this
uh war against democracy where he has a
a cyber war with us and a hot war in
Ukraine it the longer it goes on the
more his days are numbered I believe so
this go ahead they're having protests
right now they've got Mothers Against
The War uh he's losing the people he's
losing the people you know and when you
lose the moms you're in trouble you know
I mean and and the only thing he has
left to Galvanize them with because
it's in these people's DNA to be afraid
of us it just is their entire lifetime
they have been raised to fear us and the
only thing he has is is they'll show
this Drone footage they'll show it in
Russia and they'll say it was over
Russian territory they will say it is it
wasn't a spy drone it was an attack
drone and oh by the way we had a village
hit not too long ago
um you know the ukrainians the the
resistance inside Russia oh there are no
rights remember they're already writing
this stuff as you speak
on Russian TV I mean it's and it's all
they have left and Biden is way too
smart for this this is why I'm like this
was the man for this time because he is
just so
I guarantee you he's like
okay right whatever okay whatever you
want to do I mean if if that's how you
if that's how you want to lead this into
um the next presidential race then be my
guest because that that is truly
um I mean again we go back to this
banking crisis where these Republicans
were trying to make it as a woke Bank
was failing because they're woke and it
fell flat on its face they lose the plot
at every turn it's the same plot line
that they're losing that Russia is
somehow the greatest Ally and they're
the they're the beacon of freedom and
democracy like get the [__] out of here
you you [__] dumbass free dumb
Patriots don't know what you're talking
about and you're losing the plot line
time and time and time again when they
when they act like zielinski is a Nazi
because he's defending his democracy
from an attack from Putin this is this
is all ridiculous the
Ukraine did not go into Russia to try to
take over that cyber nation that is not
what happened and if you go back and you
look at I don't know Nazi Germany what
Hitler did that's what Hitler did is go
to Sovereign Nations and take them and
to be quite honest Putin was hoping that
he would have the the [__] welcome
that Hitler had in Austria and it didn't
happen it didn't happen he totally
underestimated
freedom and liberty and what the
Ukrainian people want in freedom and
liberty even as weak and as corrupt as
their democracy is even just the slight
hint of democracy and Liberty is worth
fighting for and he he totally
underestimated the Ukrainian people and
really underestimated uh the western
western liberal democracies of the world
that we would back them I think
um and it's it's going to be to his
demise here but um so that's the news
right now is that a Russian fighter has
taken down a U.S Air Force drone over
the Black Sea so we'll see what what
develops there go ahead Texas ball if
you got one last long never believe your
own [__]
never believe your own [__] that
ended Vladimir Putin ended him well in
the Republican party it's going to end
the Republican party here Texas Paul
because they're doing the same [__]
[__] they're they're that is why you
have [__] boxes like James Comer going
on Fox News over the weekend and saying
it's because awokism is why this Bank
collapsed which is nowhere near the
[__] it doesn't make sense so let
alone being Tethered to any kind of
reality he believes that [__]
Ron DeSantis believes that wokism is the
enemy and he has to crush wokism
whatever the [__] that is that that is
their delusion coming to fruition
absolutely in in their [__] where
Wrestlemania meets real life I've said
this a long time rest we're at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life and they're believing the
Wrestlemania [__] as real life now that
they've just bought it hook line Sinker
they believe their own [__] like
you're saying uh the Republican party
that is
yeah and it's it's
almost too easy because you know you
know me Tony I never say I say don't
talk to these sons of [__] you're not
going to reach them you're not going to
reach them ever this is the one
exception the one caveat to that is when
reality punches them in the face this
freaking hard you know I had a
discussion with a guy on social media
the other day he's like well well my
company uses svb I can't believe you're
saying let it collapse and I went out
because I was saying
protect the depositors not the
shareholders no bailouts sell it off if
you have to but make the depositors
whole he's like well my company uses
that well yeah dumbass your company is
one of the depositors yeah I am this is
an opportunity to reach into these
people and grab a hold of them because
right now tiny D's [__] with Disney
seems really [__] stupid
it seems really [__] stupid when
you're saying oh [__] is my Regional
Bank gonna close
you know you know this is when we have
to reach in speaking of tiny D here's a
video that was uh just played this is at
I think a DeSantis event and they're
talking about media here let's see what
they're saying
can we please go with the other media
okay
so it looks like what is happening in
This Club Texas poll is the media is
trying to get in to ask Ron DeSantis
questions and guess what they're doing
guess what they're doing they're only
letting certain outlets in I wonder I
wonder if those Outlets are sympathetic
to Ron DeSantis or not I wonder yeah
yeah you know it could be that right let
me tell you something I'm telling you
folks and I know you think I'm [__]
crazy because it sounds crazy that
Rhonda santis is not going to get in
this race but I'm telling you I don't
believe he's going to he is such a weak
[__] [__] ass [__] and he it is
unraveling in front of him when he went
on his little National book tour he
realized that his his [__] policies
that he's doing in Florida it does not
play to the rest of the country this
fascist nonsense does not play to the
rest of the country and he's not going
to win in [__] Pennsylvania he's not
going to win in Arizona he won't win in
Ohio he won't win in Michigan
in a general election he can't [__]
win in a general election not only can
he not win he can't take States like
Alabama he can't take Louisiana he will
not take these Trump counties in [__]
Ohio in Ohio folks in Ohio in the
[__] town of Palestine or Donald
Trump's policies destroyed that [__]
town they welcomed him with open arms
and they [__] love him there they
were wearing [__] flags as capes and
had signs saying welcome we're glad you
destroyed our town
I'm telling you they are the cult is not
ready to turn on Trump
and Ronda Santos is figuring this out
that's why he's doing this he's doing
this not because
um he's trying well he's a [__] uh
Texas Ball but what he's trying to do
here
is he's trying to make sure that there's
no Outlets that make a fool of him that
Donald Trump can find an attack point
because that's the truth in it and
that's what we as the country need to
encourage is Donald Trump attacking Ron
desantos we have to encourage this we
have to drive this wedge because they're
going to lose the plot line more and
more and more because As Trump attacks
descent desantos Trump has to do more of
the wokism [__] and desantos has to do
more of it and they're going to get in
this [__] mode where they're going to
turn off every single person in this
country that wants to vote for them and
that that is how I get to the number of
14 to 16 million in the margin in the
general election
um Let me let me finish see what this
clip is and I'll let you give commentary
this is a public school
sir I've asked you please
I need to have the media we're done here
with the press conference so we need to
have the media was a press conference
but you took no press questions
it's over please step back
to supporter right there oh yeah
unfortunately that's that's how you're
going to get they're asking for you guys
to please keep the premises I'm sure
he's got his crab Boy shirt underneath
his um his cop outfit there I'm just
saying
um
you know I've got my plan already for
the for tiny D I already do because when
Trump goes down
there's going to be Communications of
tiny D just absolutely enthralled with
with all of the the the the
indictments and and Trump going down and
Trump lives in Florida and Tiny D will
not have protected him
and that will be it that will be it all
the trumpers out there you remember when
they tried to drive the when they when
they did drive the wedge between the
Hillary voters and the Bernie voters
right a [__] men brother a [__]
men tiny D [__] Trump
that I will be screaming that from every
roof everywhere just to make sure that
they know that tiny D for his own
selfish [__] desires
fisted Trump every chance he got he did
not protect him well the other the other
thing we need to make sure that we Stoke
here and draw a wedge in that in that
fight uh Ronda Santa's giving up or are
not protecting Trump is to get Trump to
respond to that we have to get Trump to
do videos and social media posts that
Ron DeSantis is a traitor Ron DeSantis
never liked Trump he was always a never
Trumper I mean this is what this is and
the cult will follow they will follow
the cult will follow down that road and
I'm telling you I don't know if you
remember 2020 Texas Ball but there was a
pandemic going on and it was going to be
very dangerous to vote very [__]
dangerous to vote I mean a lot your life
was at risk in some places in some
places uh those people's lives are at
risk but people got out and there was
almost a margin of 8 million people the
largest [__] vote we've ever had in a
presidential election in this country
um it was one of the largest percentages
of population that voted in in modern
history and we're going to see that
number talked in 2024 because we've seen
record numbers in the last midterm
because we're yelling and screaming and
people are sick and tired of their
[__] and people know that they have
to engage in their democracy they know
they have to use the power of their
ballot to get rid of these [__]
fascists like Rhonda Santos and Donald
Trump and I'm telling you I'm telling
you if we use our power of the
microphone and we draw these wedges and
get them to fight each other we will 100
percent win in 2024 and I'm not just
talking about the presidency because
that's an important seat but folks we
have to win these Senate races we have
to win this house back so that we have
some sanity back into our legislator
that we can actually get some [__]
[__] done and not talk about Hunter
Biden's dick and elon's [__] Twitter
files the more the more we put Sandy in
this the better
their own voters sent him a message in
2022. you know the Republicans
historically should have rolled Us in
2022 they should have the midterms they
should have just rolled us their own
voters told them we're sick of this [__]
we're sick of the crazy we're sick of
the nonsense we you know you you have to
do be competent and do your job and the
Republicans said hold my bear here's
little Jimmy Jordan we're going to give
him some committees and we're going to
talk about how you know the the
government is just attacking us that's
that's what we're going to talk about is
the government's attacking us we're
gonna you know it's just one damn thing
after another the twit files oh my God
just as a Democrat I was like what a
gift what a gift oh thank God
a gift with the January 6 footage again
their stupidity their stupidity is
boundless and they're Shameless in it
and they don't understand that it's
their biggest downfall in this in in
this entire in this entire campaign that
happened in 2022 and that will happen in
2024. they're [__] they just are uh
we're running out of time Texas Paul I
appreciate you joining us today on on
Tuesdays as always uh give us your
Shameless plug here tell us where to
find you
yeah every Sunday folks come on and join
me uh it's every Sunday at nine Central
I'm doing Sunday coffee with Texas Polo
grab a mug get your lazy ass out of bed
and come join me at 9 Central uh you can
you can the link for it you can find it
www.realtexaspaul.com and the link is
down in the description below
realtexasball.com also don't forget we
are on fire suspension here at the Tony
Michaels podcast go subscribe to the
main channel the Tony Michaels podcast
is [__] free it's free it didn't cost
you a thing to subscribe also subscribe
at the up wire uh where we were
broadcasting from on our suspension uh
so go to the up wires Channel you go to
upwire.com follow their Twitter account
too I think they're going to be tweeting
from that Twitter account speaking of
Twitter and elon's Twitter and twit
files follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google and
make sure you follow us on Facebook at
the Tony Michaels you can watch us over
there as well another place you can
watch the show is on Twitch Texas ball
did you know that I I get part of Jeff
bezos's Money talking about getting a
Billionaire's money I'm gonna please
well that's you know
that's the best way to make money Tony
it's the best way to make money they
show up they watch you that's right it's
not it's not merch purchases it's not
all the other stuff that we have to have
to keep things going that's the straight
up advertisement dollars paying you Amen
brother that's right so so if you got
here's how it works if you've got an
Amazon Prime account just go link it to
Twitch
um and you get one free subscription on
Twitch with your Amazon Prime account
which pays US money it's not a lot it's
like two or three dollars but they add
up over time and again it's billionaires
money so why it's the best kind of money
you can get and it doesn't cost you a
single dime if you're a prime prime uh
Amazon Prime subscriber so just go link
your Twitch and Amazon Prime account if
you're not sure how to do it just Google
it how do I link my Amazon Prime account
and twitch and it'll show you and then
you give the free subscription to us
here at the Tony Michaels podcast and it
supports us so and thank you very much
and the other thing too uh go to the
Tony michaels.com again I have the the
promo code for the [__] em hats the 10
off so you go to the Tony michaels.com
go down to the hat store click that
everyone's asking for [__] hats and
they wanted a promo code so I delivered
here today yeah so so get your [__] em
hat you can get 10 off just use the
promo code podcast or use the promo code
hacks10 that's hats10 at D Tony
michaels.com scroll down hit the uh the
hat store or you can go to
hats.thedonymichaels.com hats dot the
Tony michaels.com that'll get you there
too uh but visit us at the Tony
michaels.com check out my patreon page
there's more and more members
you like the blue and here's the ear let
me give you a a view here's here's the
blue one right here there's the blue one
right there here actually you know what
here I'll I'll show you I'll show you
the blue one here's here's the blue one
right here so there's the blue I like
that's the one I like if you like the
Democrat blue I like the red because I
want to make Red Hats wearable again
um I actually maybe I should make a hint
that says I make Red Hats wearable again
but um and that's the campaign so if you
like there's pink ones over there
there's black ones
um there's the kind that I wear which is
this there's the snapback hats so
there's a lot of different options over
there on the hat store so again just go
to the Tony michaels.com click the hat
store link it'll take you there and use
the promo code podcast or the promo code
hats10
and you get 10 off your purchase Texas
Paul thanks for joining us I appreciate
this I can't wait um next week we'll we
should have Gabe with us I know that's
one of your favorite Parts about coming
here on the Tony Michaels podcast is
shooting the [__] with Gabe so next week
he should be back I think he's going to
be back on Thursday so tomorrow to be me
alone maybe I'll try to get a guest
tomorrow
um to come on the show see if I can get
someone to to help us out here Texas
Paul as always thank you very much my
friend I appreciate it everyone
same time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon